mercredi soir 20h20 à champigny sur
marne un chien de race de type american
staff sans muselière va mort d'une jeune
fille de 16 ans 17/06 parvient à
prévenir des policiers de la brigade
anticriminalité alors arriver le chien
va s'attaquer à une deuxième victime
puis à un policier face à la panique et
pour stopper l'animal plusieurs
policiers vont faire usage de leur arme
et tiré à sept reprises sur le chien
la vidéo filmée par un voisin fait
actuellement le tour d'internet et
certains dénoncent les responsabilités
des policiers alors il m'a choc d'un
chien abattu par la police ont-ils eu la
bonne réaction
les images folle on va revoir ces images
tout de suite parce que je n'arrivais
égaré da belhaj qui est avec vous merci
on aime bien que vous venez nous voir
merci reda secrétaire départemental 94
unité sgp police ont marre voit juste la
vidéo regardez kaka tournée elle est
folle regardez
[Musique]
obligé
est là qui sont vos employés parce qu en
loge était pas du tout d'accord avec des
fines raymond et guillaume qui disait
pendant que non linéaire gilles et
guillaume qui disait que vous auriez pu
faire autrement à ce que vous auriez pu
faire autrement ben non alors on peut
souvent c'est déjà plus facile de
l'extérieur faut savoir que la les
collègues là le chien reste surtout
cette catégorie match 1 reste une arme
par destination sur les collègues quand
ils interviennent ils viennent pas pour
faire un contrôle d'identité ils
viennent sur un avp corporelle si elles
arrivent sur place un accident d'accord
viennent pour un banal accident une fois
sur place ils constatent qu'à une
victime au sol qui est pris en charge
par les pompiers et les pompiers
explique aux collègues qui en fait non
cette victime n'a été mordu par un chien
mais quand il ya attaché de ce côté là
haut niveau comme vous pouvez le
constater la au niveau de la résidence
d'accord et puis entre temps un individu
du quartier il vient il commence à s'en
prendre aux policiers ça tourne mal et
tout outrage rébellion interpellation le
chien s'énerve qui à proximité une jeune
fille de 15 ans ou 14 ans prend le chien
par la laisse est ici mais là et là les
policiers ils ont qu'une seule
alternative bien sûr c'est l'action et
c'est la légitime défense ou est en
plein dedans après il y avait peut-être
une autre solution mais n'est pas de
notre fait c'est la brigade cynophile on
a une brigade cynophile survol de là on
aurait pu l'appeler dès le départ lui
dire ouais vous venez pas mais oui mais
en général ils interviennent très
rapidement d'accord mais le problème
c'est que cette brigade cynophile pour
la petite histoire elle n'a pas de
véhicule en ce moment parce que c'est
pas une priorité du préfet de police
magicmaman
aucune cela est donc mais elle est le
koala la jeune fille alors les deux ont
été on connaît pas exactement leur état
mais les dons été transporté par le samu
à l'hôpital blessé parce que je vous dis
c'est la première a été mordu à la
cuisse gauche seconde à la cuisse droite
et le chien ne voulait pas lâcher je
précise je passais voit bien son image
mais ça suffit de toucher une artère est
assurée à mourir en 5 secondes
alors la question qu'on vous pose ce
soir c est ce qu ils ont eu la bonne
réaction et policiers pour moi je le dis
pour moi c'est oui
il n'ya même pas de débat là dessus mais
on va le faire quand même et guillaume
genton c'est non bah moi cette vidéo l
m'a choqué pour moi tous ceux qui
répondent oui sont dépourvus d'humanité
vraiment c'est une image horrible
comment déjà sur le chien ces sont des
chiens catégorisés tout le monde pense
que ce sont des chiens méchants agréé
six mois j'ai un chien un rottweiler ce
sont des chiens qui sont peut-être un
peu différent des autres qui ont des
réactions parfois imprévisible des
réactions de prédation et ça voilà c'est
comme ça il faut effectivement les
maîtriser les musulmans mais ce type
d'accident peuvent arriver voilà et je
pense que techniquement il aurait pu par
exemple pas et le chien le maîtriser
autrement que le tuer voilà ça c'est sur
le
sujet
il faut là c'est lui le poids normal
le principal responsable
vous
y
attendez quand même et a déjà passé car
ils nous frappent les quelque chose
connaissez
vous avez pour enlever pour que le chien
enlève sa gueule de la boule il faut
l'étrangler ouais c'est le seul truc si
vous voyez les images il bougera pas
vous dis donc c'est ça tapait et votre
bouche la drass il se passer si on remet
les images au ralenti nos collègues de
la base il arrive il lui met un couple
ça ne sert à rien de le mettre un coup
de pied le chien ne lâchera pas dans le
seul moyen je vous le dis oui il faut
l'étrangler vraiment évolué pour qui la
prise illégale et non moi j'ai répondu
tout cas pas fait tous les ans vous avez
référé sûr il faut y aller là bas donc
arrêté guillaume j'en passe je pense
pardon mais il ya d'autres solutions et
moyens lâche à coller sa photo aurait
fait quoi toi moi ça m'est déjà arrivé
et quoi tu l'auras on peut n'y a pas que
les troubles et on peut le tirer on peut
le
moi je
suis d'accord mais entraînant alors
qu'en dehors du chien sur le climat que
commente cette image on est dans un
climat de tensions sociales que tout le
monde a son flingue les quintés sert de
relais
c'est ce qu'on disait dans la fac et
cambrai leur phobie dès qu'un problème
dès qu'un signe d'agressivité faut buter
c'est ce que c'est c'est touché une
artère le chien
les panneaux zahia ya un climat en ce
moment on est désolé
c'est désert voilà c'est des êtres
vivants ils ont droit
je suis pas moi je sais c'est pas rigolo
mais te dire la la la la responsabilité
des politiques tu te rends compte si
derrière et les policiers qui sont là et
la france qui est là ils tirent pas
historien et là il ya une artère qui a
tiré on fait quoi
le chenil et
vous avez à faire le chien après il est
tranquille est en train de manger des
croquettes chèvre l'euthanasie
un chien khimki maury qui attaque et un
chien qui veut disparaître c'est un
danger public passera si ton chien et à
parce qu'il n'a pas été chose aisée il
va bouffer mon fils de 18 mois ce jour
ça va très mal se passer donc je vois
pas comment tu peux défendre ça alors
effectivement c'est cruel on aime tous
les animaux est en cause des chiens mais
que tu fais contre un chien en plus ces
chiens là on les connaît ces déchets qui
sont posés comme des armes barres des
situations extrêmes ne peuvent pas
lâcher se serait fait déchiqueter
entièrement bouffer et on tue pas le
chien non
qu'il arrive
mais non j'ai pu vivre est prévu par
gilbert deza les policiers pour moi sont
les garants de notre sécurité et ils
doivent en permanence même dansé des
situations de panique comme si la
coupure garder leur sang froid cahors or
là quand on regarde les images les
policiers n'ont pas gardé leurs
sanctions composée de la scène de
référence sur evans ils ont été agressés
j'emploie les mots par un jeune homme je
crois propriétaire du chien et qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait à l'encontre de ce jeune homme
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils n'ont pas
été bien voilà ils ont casé le jeune
homme quand j'écris de ribéry exactement
j'ai lu l'enchaînement des faits
pourquoi n'ont ils pas qu tout
simplement zaz et le chien et non pas un
non sens exactement le jeune homme est
mort et à leur sortie ils l'ont utilisée
contre le jeu à ne pas prendre le risque
oui mais c'est pourquoi non qu'il avait
plusieurs fois dit
la vie d'un chien et c'est sa greffe on
l'a déjà vous pouvez pas utiliser une
fois que vous avez utilisé tout à
l'heure une fois vous pouvez pas
l'utiliser l'aurait utilisé sous forme
de contact d'accord il ya un sujet moi
je finis et là on est dans un cas de
figure bien particulier vous avez déjà
une jeune fille qui est née en 2017 qui
allongée au sol un peu plus loin on voit
pas sur ces images et qui a été mordu
par son chien ah oui donc la sec ce
chien là déjà c'est un danger il faut
pas rentrer en attaque ça les rend si
c'était un accès parce que c'est vrai je
vous rejoins il ya des chiens qui sont
dangereux c'est le problème aujourd'hui
la question je pense c'est surtout
propriétaire aujourd'hui on ne cherche
toujours on sait pas qui c'est d'accord
un sahraoui en fait il l'avait prêté à
une défi qui s'est fait membres et c'est
tout et la vraie question c'est ça c'est
ou est propriétaire et comment il l'a
dressé son chien ou revient donc au
départ c'est un accident de la route
c'est un oui sont appelés pour un
accident de la route d'accord d'avoir un
accident de la route et qui a mal tourné
qui s'est passé non en fait c'était pas
c'était le requérant comme on appelle ça
il a il a donné les mauvaises
informations ce n'est pas un accident de
la route c'était en fait une fille qui
s'était fait mordre par un chien
d'accord elle à vous arrivez donc ça oui
oui ça et c'est vrai que c'est vrai quoi
les les autres solutions comme unis je
vous dis si on avait eu la brigade
cynophile si elle était véhiculé jour là
c'est un rêve et le matériel pour ça
c'est une nation arrivé je pense si
jamais elle avait pu assez rapidement et
puis c'est leur métier sans me mettre
une métier de neutraliser de telle
manière qu déclinaisons et après sinon
bah c'est à partir du moment où vous
êtes dans le cadre légal et légitime
défense bah vous fait usage de votre
arme les collègues qui l'ont fait
attention au tour ils ont pas viser
n'importe où on sait qu'on est donc je
regarde c'est à des gens qui disent ne
serait plus juste le blessé mais tu
oublies serait compliqué il sait très
conscient la marque sait ce que c'est
mais même si tu lui touche la pâte je
suis pas sûr a lâché
je me suis en paix dont 12 années à la
fin de plusieurs fois et que il le
savait qu'avec leur ait dit ou fait des
attaques de chiens lâche ta vie le chien
pas le seul taper il me racontait un
truc un jour il ya un chien qui aie aie
un policier qui a été mordu par un chien
un malinois il l'attrapé le bras d'un
pays si il lui a tiré dessus la cantine
on a envoyé son crâne on voyait le crâne
était déchiqueté il est encore vivant il
lâchait pas le bras c'est vraiment qu'il
mais tous ou qui alors bien sûr qu'on
aime les animaux on a pu briser le
silence et on est convoyeur on verrait
notre chien se faire tirer dessus on
serait au bout notre vie mais là les
mecs je le dis on peut pas tomber sur la
police là dessus qu'est ce que vous
voulez qu'ils vous allez faire quoi
croyez quoi ils allaient quoi il brille
parfois delphine wespiser qui dit non
alors moi j'aimerais juste dire un truc
et j'espère vous avez pas dire que je
suis hors sujet c'est bien possible
que tout le monde l'entende que toute la
france l'entendent les chiens ne sont
pas méchants ils sont méchants lorsque
l'humain lui donne des consignes je suis
d ermont la dîme est propriétaire à fait
vrai nom mais voilà ça c'est vrai mais
ça changera la scène mais quel rapport
ok merci à vérifier je peux rien on sait
pas qui est son chien mais jce le
propriétaire s est laissé à ses
propriétaires locaux le pro ferry on va
pas dire où il
n'y a pas de catégories france il
faudrait que quand on est un chien on
apprenne le béaba de ce combo guitare
d'acheter on sait pas où je ne sais pas
d'où il devait même est ce que je mets
le nez de matisse en fout lemaitre et
usain personnel qui m'arrive ya trois
jours ou pas enfin oui
mais c'est bon et ben c'est non mais
c'est bon on va laisser dit nous mais
bon là on est au j'aimerais que vous
réagissiez sur la scène mais j'ai rien à
dire sur la scène il faut juste que les
gens iraient directement l'argent sale
et debrecen hun et l'adolescent ne sais
quoi vous dit quoi sur l'adolescente
delphine qu'ils ont si près j'ai c'est
beau non mais on sait que vous aimez
beaucoup les animaux mais excusez moi on
peut pas nous dire vous êtes en train de
vous faire un truc général on n'est pas
dans 30 millions d'amis ici oui elle
atteindra s'il ya des chiens méchants ce
parce qu'il ya déjà il ya des manières
des maîtres à la vieillesse nous parle
de mètres on sait même pas qui est le
maître de ce chien on va dire quoi on va
appeler on va dire oh j'ai été où t'as
pas le nom mais c'est vrai le truc là
c'est sur la scène là je sais que ça
fait mal de voir ce chien abattu et que
c'est pas lui et on sait que c'est pas
lui le responsable c'est que c'est son
maître on l'a dit mais ça même pas qui
est son maître mais aujourd'hui les
gérants actions réagissent sur la scène
et aujourd'hui on voit passer un break
de faire d'aussi un élément qu'on oublie
quand même sauf un an de ma part
monsieur le chien on le voit sur la
vidéo il est attaché le cheikh a tâché
syrie
c'est
fondamentalement oui tirs au moment où
il tire pour moi mais je suis désolé on
est
attaché donc à partir du moment où le ch
est attaché je pense qu'on peut le
neutraliser regardez là
il peut très vite après cyril mais
arrête de ses frères de la vidéo où le
sua minutes à des morts que la fille a
posteriori sur une scène tarifs sur une
scène policiers de la dipj en gamine qui
est né en 2017 qui est par terre au sol
déjà tu es déjà tu étais pas et pas dans
son état normal tu as un policier était
là pour sauver les gens là vous êtes en
train de dire on a tué le chien mais oui
si on a tué le chien c'est malheureux
mais est-ce qu'on a sauvé des gens mais
il à la question c'est oui on a sauvé
des gens tu dis le chien attaché je suis
d'accord avec toi il attaché mais ce qui
la portent et d'attraper la gorge de la
fille oui la porte et d'attraper la
gorge mais qu'il ait ouvert la garantie
des capitaux 100 tu fais quoi les gars
on fait quoi on pu sauver la physique
aux lèvres anesthésie de quoi qu'il
arrive c'est malheureux parce que son
connard de m il n'a pas mis une
muselière il est emmené à tort comme ça
règle le problème c'est le connard de
mettre à l'essai ce chien son museau les
chiens il est mort parce que son maître
était un connard et j'espère qu'on va
quitter en
finale finale aura les animaux n'a pas
cherché est touché par cette scène mais
il n'y avait pas le chercher lui aurait
dit qu'est ce que tu aurais fais toi dis
moi je sais pas ce que j'aurais fait on
peut pas laisser filer
ce que je veux expliquer c'est que j'ai
eu le cas mes voisins ont pris un chien
de catégorie qui est un chien méchant et
toujours avec la muselière il voulait
bouffer tout le monde et où machin je
lis je leur expliquais le b à ba avec un
chien ont six mois gérant du soutien
fantastique pat avait chez moi là bas
c'est juste vous expliquer truc en six
mois je les rangs du fantastique au
final les gens se sont séparés la
maîtresse elle donne plus signe de vie
le mari voulait rien à [ __ ] de ce cher
vous même c'est moi qui l'a pris sur le
canal il ya deux jours il est allé le
ramena l'espère en tout cas moi ça me
fait mal au cul que les gens
n'apprennent pas
méchant d'accord et c'est chiant
chanteur est commode comme ça
charles humain c'est le problème
que tu fais je ne sais pas bah tu fais
quoi mais c'est pour ça que je vous dis
il faut prendre l'autre camp baquet à
l'émission ces questions pressantes le
bo ce n'est même pas
dire ce que je vous dis encore mieux
être de prendre les choses en amont oui
mais des livres et films tu assures
honnêtement et ciry-le-noble pas de
finale mais pourquoi tu souffles et
parce que la tuer on est on est dans
l'urgence des droïdes et oui mais tu vas
pas dire j'ai trouvé mais on sait très
bien que sega cause de son maître que ce
chien il venait que ça c'est lui c'est
vrai s'il en a rien à [ __ ] du sheridan
sais même pas qui c'est
qui va dire quoi tu vas arriver là bas
bien tomber je vais aller chercher le
mec rungis posé la question à delphine
si la petite gamine de gainey en 2017 le
chien il a tu es ce que le chien on le
laisse en vie ou pas non non bah voilà
donc s'armer emmène alors j'ai entendu
mon expérience j'ai dit mais sans mais
un chien mais je me méfie une touchante
une expérience
dans ce qu'on dit c'est touchant ce que
tu dis oui d et sur le long terme a
souvent raison sur tel raisonnement là
il n'y a même pas de débat est ce qu on
me dira faut une fois une fois bravo la
police bravo mais à police est arrivée
sar et la voûte et d'entendre résonner
jetons avec de la raison est arrivé sur
un terrain où 4 5 secondes à prendre une
décision pour sauver un enfant n'y a pas
de débat ils ont tué un chien quand un
chien tu attrapes des cambrioleurs n'ont
déjà parlé c'est qui redoute plus une
fois qu'ils avaient fini il avait cinq
secondes pour décider pour sauver un
gamin oui bravo la police et au
président du sang froid j'y vais pas
d'une question parlementaire ump c'est
des sujets à chaque fois qu'ils sont des
exemples donc moi je dis juste j'élargis
un peu le truc je dis j'espère comme ce
sera la loi tchouta mais roseraie les
gens ils fassent un stade comme en
suisse mais un stage de deux jours
reproduise pas elle a raison sur quelque
chose c'est que le maire moi c'est sûr
le mettre au pas qu'on dise plus il
ferma c'est que le m quand il va être
arrêté il va certainement revanchards et
de 33 mois avec sursis ou une sonnerie
aime ça alors quand lui devrait s'en
tenir aux moments comme ça tu vous allez
sur le retrouve ouais on va chercher ma
vie
je vais retrouver est ce qu'elle est
juste précisé qu' il avait confié
apparemment le maître était le chien
vous pourriez on est un peu dans un
quartier en remet le contexte déjà
comment on peut prêter un chien mineurs
peinture je pense que c'est une question
qui se pose est là une petite mineurs de
14 15 ans qui se baladent alarmant de la
personne avec une arme et chez saute
dessus et puis et puis il la mort voilà
nous qu'on arrive le chien il a attaché
on va pas voir le chien on va pas tiré
sur le chien on ne fait rien c'est à
bord au moment où il ya eu le gène qui
est venu s'interposer ou la fille s'est
fait mordre et là on interviewe voilà
comme vous l'avez dit on à argy et puis
les collègues ce qui est beau mais la
justice c'est que la bague champigny ils
ont été super réactif et sur une image
comme ça c'est pas facile puisque voyez
des badauds bien sûr il y a personne qui
est blessé et ça chez vous ça bien sûr
guillaume genton moi je suis très touché
parce que d'idées le film qui est la
seule personne sensible autour de la
terre on est alors c'est la seule
personne sensible non mais c'est vrai et
on parle souvent des specis taire le
fait de hiérarchiser les espèces la
caisse on y voit sur les images en multi
les chiens voit sur les images
exit qu'est ce que nous disent ces
images que la vie d'un chien ne voyons
rien non
et la garde et ô combien de temps entre
le moment où le policier intervient au
moment où il tue le chien deux secondes
il met un coup de pied mais une belle
n'a pas d'accord je suis désolé c'est la
gorge de la fille mais j'aimerais qu'ils
voilà qu'on se pose la question dans
l'autre sens est ce que tu penses que la
vie d'un enfant bromont la vie d'un
chien je pense que
ça a vraiment à ça a répondu oui mais
moi ça me brise le coeur de voir ces
images
je
dis pas que c'est bien qu'un enfant
meurt jeune en question al-essaoui la
vie d'un enfant vaut la vie d'un chien
noir
[Applaudissements]
m
alors de voir des couleurs non mais là
c'est cette image et les dégâts
sont les chiens et moi j'ai mon nom et
des chiens catégorisés pass enfant est
la dernière de problème alors hier déjà
le monde alors c'est un crève-coeur de
passer pour des monstres c'est toi
non mais
gérer la chien collage un vrai problème
si un mec qui chante une jolie boutique
il est difficile non mais pour répondre
à guillaume parce qu'il est en train de
dire moi je très honnêtement et j'aime
mon chien mais par dessus tout et c est
qu il est extrêmement difficile et je
pourrais je prends des cours avec
quelqu'un qui vient régulièrement pour
l'éduquer et le chien et moi d'accord
parce que effectivement il est
extrêmement compliqué mais il s'attaque
pas aux êtres humains ils s'attaquent
aux autres chiens donc la balade est
compliquée avec les autres chiens excuse
moi si demain ils venaient s'attaquer à
un enfant eh bien je dirais je suis
désolé effectivement et les temps qui
sommes crèvera le clac et j'en
pleurerais c'est normal politiques
ont-ils sauvé la vie d'un chien oui mais
je vais vous avec moi on répondait lines
avait répondait rapidement ne vaut pas
la vie d'un chien est bon mais vous êtes
en train avec tout le respect que je
vous dois et vous aussi mathieu de
travestir une bande vidéo et ça c'est
pas bien il ya des gars qui se travestit
si c'est toi
et vous nous entraîner sur un terrain et
monsieur j'espère que vous allez être
honnête qui n'est pas le bon c'est la
vie de l'enfant n'était plus en danger
jacquet sait d'où je viens de
finir la vie de l'enfant et p
heureusement leur a
serré mais
à voir la vidéo
[Applaudissements]
c'est une jeune fille
c'est la vie d'un enfant de 15 ans
joint nombreux cadeaux tiens tu tirais
finirait pas les sommets quatre
policiers répondent les new data et âme
et la vie de l'enfant mais en plus en
danger bref s'ils arrêtent leurs études
mais la tb que chez moi c'est le bras de
mise en danger de la vie dure personne
ne faut pas de là des
temps le dira il n'y avait pas de mise
en danger de la vie d'une personne en
la personne qui est sur la vidéo la
jeune ado
ça y est de mise mais parce que vous le
voyez le chien l'a re la dame et moi
j'ai dit
vous voyez qu'elle est dégagée syrien et
d'eau
fraîche championne en fait le lyonnais
trade à tétouan
tétouan au monde connaît qui tire le
chien s'affairent toujours sur la cuisse
de la jeune fille soit de la jeune fille
je vous précise le premier tir et les
six autres mais
non mais non tu sais quoi vous êtes
c'était un bon match il que je leur dis
bien sûr toutes tes prises de position
les cantines joe esposito le dit je te
le dit hein donc j'existe avait la tâche
young et differdange est attention
schyle il fallait tirer t'attendant voit
un petit peu les réactions à tu retires
[Rires]
chance vous tirez une fois
la mêlée et j'aime juste après si les
bulls ils vont là c'est un chien s'il
est blessé ou ici moins sûr voilà ce
sera new line et on l'aurait d'ailleurs
une citation à l'orée du et quand même
ces gens qui n'ont pas sur la mairie
loin
des 16 ans qui sont pas sur le terrain
et je crois qu'il allait tirer les
malgré nous ce qu'on fait là maintenant
c'est
un peu une bande vidéo oui vous avez été
ta fille ton nadeau qu'à peu près ça
bien sûr qu'on essaye de très bonnes
questions il rencontre concrètement tour
et les oies olala messieurs les
policiers vous avez vraiment eu le temps
vous auriez dû d'abord interviewé le
chien demandé la présidente vous laissez
moi à ma fille mesure de cambriolages a
demandé qu'est ce que tu fais comment tu
veux concrètement que la police a été
extradé concrètement qu'il réagisse
gillot didymo asie battement médias il
valait pas la base il
répond et répond à la question quel café
tu sais quoi
le chien l'a fait quoi si cette affiche
j'essaye de max traire du sentiment qui
nous touche là
qu'est ce qu'elle fait si cet avis est
affilée j'aurai le même jugement tu fais
quoi jarrett mais je fais que moi je
demande à la police de garder son sang
froid
tu gardes ton sang-froid temps qu'enfin
tout et par 3
066 toi brillé
à l'invitation pour griller d'épuiser
foutu tu as mis ton cerveau dans un gris
portés au sein de dire aux gens depuis
des semaines le cambriolage ou pour
tenir un chien il peut la vie d'un
enfant dans la vie d'un animal sur métal
est fait par l'état répondait caméra
l'apprendre et aux poudres au palais je
crois qu'il va partir trois semaines
avec un taux aujourd'hui
répondez-leur mesdames messieurs
mesdames messieurs reda belhadj voilà là
dans ce cas là vous savez très bien
qu'il y avait une alternative
au colisée serait ce le répondent
tétouan et non non il n'ya pas
d'alternance a pas d'alternative ans par
des soldats ratissaient les élagueurs
vous êtes une personne qui est en quête
en danger ou veut-il jeu m'a plu à
pattes poursuit tant il n'ya pas les gps
que directeur supercar est justement les
collègues ils ont été très forts comme
gîte alors parce qu'ils ont géré tout
l'environnement aucun adversaire
juste avant d'avoir encore une réaction
de guillaume van houtte chaufferie jane
labatut ambitions il va d un dessert et
regarder ainsi rabaissée ça y est la
glace et qui fait croire qu'on n'aime
pas les animaux
étaient passés rien sur rien vous dites
que ça vaut rien et ça vaut une vidéo
non la vie d'une adolescente donc pas
d'accord alors moi je crois qu'à une
injustice profonde c'est qu'il ya des
humains qui tuent d'autres humains
volontairement avec l'intention de le
faire et on dit ah nan nan faut surtout
pas les tuer faut surtout et voilà parce
que voilà pas de peine de mort et c'est
un animal attaque attend qu'ils
s'attaquent qui ne tue pas qu'ils
s'attaquent à quelqu'un c'est une
réaction qui malheureusement n'est n'est
pas fait sciemment les chiens ne veut
pas s'attaquer à la personne au fond
c'est le cd oui ça s'appelle des
rédactions céder american animal est un
être humain
voilà six ans
les futés immédiatement c'est
dégueulasse
mais bien pour ça qu'un animal et à nu
un être humain c'est pas pareil comme tu
dis là ne réaliserait une réaction de
prédation des faits que oui c'est pas un
être humain c'est bien c'est bien la
vidéo s'agirait d'ailleurs la fête du
mariage il fallait veut dire qu'en fait
là vous êtes en train de nous dire que
les policiers ont tué par plaisir c'est
à dire qu'ils sont là ils sont tués
c'est ça si on suit votre raisonnement
chez chat et par manque de sang froid
annoncé qu'ils se prennent pas la tête
c'est un problème en tirer il ya un
problème
oxyradio l'échangé as commencé que sa
vie était
vêtu comme un jour
il ya des gens qui se malheureusement
c'est très très peu plus pas encourager
ça c'est pas des prises il ya des gens
qui se font mordre tous les jours par
des chats il faut buter tous les chiens
et pas du
fait je fais pas déchiquetés par des
rentrées du fait qu'elle ait jamais
attaquer
ici c'est comme les cambriolages et si
celui-ci l'avait tirée du tonton
l'histoire
c'est le cerveau cramé par les couleurs